turnout at polling stations in the
capital bangi was visibly low the
government of Central African Republic's
President faustan arshons tuadera says
the Constitutional changes will bring
stability and help development to
adara's critics say he's trying to stay
in power
I think the Central African people have
asked for it and I think the people will
vote in favor for this new fundamental
law twadar has been president since
2015. the Constitutional changes would
enable him to stay in office for another
16 years
political opposition and rights groups
say they've been threatened and attacked
for campaigning against the changes
unfortunately we're in a situation where
we witnessing firsthand the
establishment of dictatorship by Mr
tuadera so therefore cannot be we cannot
have any uh referendum free and fair
that's the reason why we have decided uh
opposition side to boycott the
referendum
government depends on Russian
mercenaries from the Wagner group and
Rwandan soldiers to control bangi and
some of the towns
the foreign forces benefit from access
to the vast mineral wealth including
gold and diamonds
armed groups control much of the
countryside they also ordered people to
boycott the referendum
for many people the threat of violence
and economic hardship are of Greater
concern than the politics
about half the population is in need of
humanitarian Aid and about half a
million people have been forced from
their homes
Decades of coups and conflict led to a
new constitution being adopted in 2016
the government now wants to change it
provisional results are expected after a
week Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera
Cesar Publix is the dialogues advisor on
Africa at Consolation resources that's
an international organization committed
to peace building he says such
referendums are a tool used to hold on
to political power
we need to step back and actually
understand Central African Republic it's
a very fragile state it is surrounded by
fragile States is south of south of
church and west of South Sudan so
effectively
this referendum is more of one of the
instruments that the elite use uses as
they are bugging it's really an
occupation of the political Elite in
Central African Republic in bangi and
and and and both the government and the
armed groups the elite in in bangi are
actually kind of negotiating their
positions in in governments there is no
actually there is no particular
ideological difference between the
position and government is more of
everybody is struggling for power and
this referendum is just one instrument
that the president wants to use to
actually open up the space for really
what because they the presidential term
limit because he was elected in 2015 and
also 2020 and his his term is up so he
wants to be re-elected in 2025 again so
his argument is very very
straightforward that yeah if for central
Africa Republic requires stability and
he sees this as part of a part of really
the stability that is required to to
stabilize this this country that has
been recycled of violence over decades